I really need to understand why you
think this dolly program can we talk
about AI in general yeah yeah let's have
a little AI discussion that you're not
going to exist in five years because AI
is just gonna do reviews for you I've
I've already submitted that there's
enough high definition video of me and
my voice online that I will inevitably
be cloned and deep faked into Oblivion
and I won't need to exist it's just a
fact all of us won't need to exist yeah
this is where I don't get it geez they
tried to do this they've tried to do a
stand-up special only done in AI I think
Netflix started to pull it out and uh
yeah did it suck well I mean I think it
was on par with a lot of Netflix uh
there was no jokes there was nothing it
didn't understand they didn't understand
like the math of a joke and because a
lot of ways the joke isn't only math
right and your reviews aren't going to
be only math right so there's nothing
human in it and that's what we I think
appreciate even if we're reviewing Tech
somebody's like oh I like the way that
guy does it he has a charm to him yes so
when you said this program Dolly which
you guys should describe to the people
listening right now because there's no
way I can [ __ ] describe it dolly
dolly okay Dolly by open AI basically
it's just a a prompt it's a it's a text
box field you put in whatever text you
want and it will generate from scratch
an image that resembles whatever you
type and you can be as detailed as you
want you can add adjectives you can add
actions things like that you could just
type in horse flying a helicopter and it
will just make an image actually a bunch
of images of what it thinks a horse
flying a helicopter would look like
which is pretty cool because it's
looking at all these other different
photos that exist on the internet it
figures out what a horse is it figures
out what a helicopter is it figures out
what flying means which means it'll
probably put it in the helicopter like
at the controls and then add some
context like a sky and it's actually
really impressive so there you go you
don't even really see yeah there's a
there's a horse isn't it sure horse
flying a helicopter
some and some of them are this sucks
yeah most of them are actually not that
great but I've given it some really
simple prompts where it was kind of just
like fun to get a creative start to
making something like we have a graphic
designer at our studio where it's like
we'll give a just a random prompt of
like a thumbnail idea and we get more
ideas from Dolly and then we go ah that
actually this framing where you have the
helicopter above the camera instead of
just next to it maybe let's try
something like that so you get ideas
from it but then we always go back to
the human thing but also the tech world
is reacting to the potential of the tech
whereas you guys are reacting to the
current status no this sucks but I do
think uh robots will kill us all but go
on this game back in like the 90s you'd
be like the internet's stupid no that
[ __ ] was fire no no I know oh you said
it was too
it makes that sound yeah okay so so what
you told me that dolly is gonna replace
stand-up comedy songs in the future in
all of us how no it's not but here's
here's why I'll tell you why this is
going to get better and better and it's
super I believe it's gonna get
exceedingly photorealistic high
resolution better and better at figuring
out what words mean and that's amazing
and the tech is going to get better but
I still think we always want a human
element of everything whether it's in
our entertainment or in our creative
stuff I kind of look at it like sports
where like
in basketball for example
coaches coaching staff were always
looking at analytics what is
mathematically the best way to win a
game and like sometimes that means more
threes sometimes that means more free
throws whatever it is we're going to
mathematically find out the best thing
to do but you still need a little bit of
the human element to like actually make
a basketball game to watch I don't want
to watch AI play chess I want to watch
humans play the thing right so no matter
how good this gets like you might be
able to make an Incredible video of a
stand-up comedian with an hour-long
special with genuinely hilarious jokes
but if we know that that's not a human
making that we're less interested yeah I
think you still need the human part of
the creative I feel the same way because
I feel like when a human being does
something it says something about us yes
and that when I see a human being like
run a marathon in an hour and a half or
something yes I go that's saying
something about me as a human being and
it's amazing that they were able to
accomplish this feat if I were to see
some type of like AI or a robot run a
marathon I'd be like oh you should run
a sculpture or a painting and it's
beautiful and it's amazing it's just
something about me as a human being that
another human being like me could do
something so beautiful and and it's it's
definitively new where like dolly
these are technically new but it is
actually taking information from just
human-made things millions and millions
of human-made images for to figure out
what a new human-made image might look
when I push back on that is that's what
human beings do that's true but it just
feels different for you to come up with
a unique idea I also don't think you
have necessarily you don't have to you
can choose how much of that to draw from
where like dolly is going to go I want
to make
this because I know what a horse looks
like and I know what a helicopter looks
like I I therefore will create this set
of things and like you can get infinite
versions and you can figure out what
dolly is looking at well that's the
infinite versions thing is interesting
to me because yesterday I think it was
Mark was telling me that
if Dolly gets sophisticated enough there
could be a movie that I'm watching
that's made by Dolly that is made
specifically to my interests a different
ending different everything yeah and
you're not watching the same thing I'm
watching which is not what I think
humans want I think humans want shared
experiences that's why we love Sunday
night nine o'clock HBO show and
everybody's watching and it feels great
but it is interesting it could be
completely curated to my interests but
when you're scrolling content on your
phone that's not necessarily communal
you just like to see cool things that
you like yeah everybody's for you pages
and if the AI is able to make that in
the same way that like five years ago
would be like hey did you see these
three pictures in a row you'd be like or
now if you said you see these three
pictures in a row on Instagram you'd say
no yeah because your three pictures is
different than my three pictures right
it would be as focused as one piece of
content hey did you see this piece of
content and yes you would say no because
it doesn't exist to anyone else except
for you yes that's where things get a
little gnarly and that's maybe even too
isolating like I don't want to exist in
a world where I'm the only one seeing
these things but you're also the only
one that gets to show people and you get
to share and say look what I see and
then those people go oh that's less
enjoyable than what I say I don't like
that as much as mine it's similar enough
that's the thing it is what you enjoy
the most you might miss the experience
but the experience of watching it it's
what you enjoy no you're right you're
right it is before you page on crack
yeah yeah for your page is a reflection
of what you want you yes yes yes that
for a few people I know it's for y'all
yeah but soon it's gonna be for you yeah
yeah yeah because watching someone
else's for you is garbage bro yeah I
judge the [ __ ] out of my friends yeah
yeah when I pull yeah we pulled up our
friend Ben's for you Paige and it was
just diesel ass weight lifting girls I
was like what what are you clicking on
me what's your for you Paige I got a
good mix it's funny I was just thinking
I'll show you mine I'll show you he's
not showing us the iPhone he's showing
us the gym
accounts okay same account all right
tick tock let's see let's see what pops
up and I follow maybe three accounts
should I go to okay it's Ultimate
Frisbee
[Music]
good idea uh this is a highlight from
the team I play on that's that could be
more for me yeah that's extreme uh yeah
and it's not even me following so that's
pretty good uh this is
I get a lot of uh educational so it'll
be like somebody explaining like you
didn't know this about this so whether
it's like a sugar cube or some cooking
thing or like some Animal Kingdom thing
I get a lot of that
um a lot of pet short pet videos a lot
of dogs on my for you page
a lot of pet videos another pet video
some of these yeah some of these just
not sure what that is
a lot of car stuff although this is over
time that was kind of sick I'm liking
that one that's pretty sick
an ad
for you got no hoes on here that's what
I was thinking
let's see how long before I hold it up
yeah oh you do
right married or just go over girlfriend
yes
it's crazy post Malone
come on some guy who's
there we go
that's your take that's right away that
has zero that has one comment and zero
likes I know that is for you that is
incredible
how does this happen weird this is just
my photo album what is this yeah dude